GOOD MORNING WELCOME TO
ME TWELVE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
HEARING WE HAVE TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY TWO BILLS TO CONSIDER
THIS MORNING BEFORE WE BEGAN I
HAVE A FEW HOUSEKEEPING NOTES-
TO COVER I WANT TO THANK IN
ADVANCE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND MR STONE FOR
COVERING VACANCIES AND THE
COMMITTEE TODAY- WE'RE KEEPING
VISIBLE DISTANCING IN THE
HEARING ROOM SO IF YOU COME
INTO THE HEARING ROOM PLEASE
ABIDE BY THAT YOU HAVE TO WEAR
A MASK IF YOU'RE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AS WELL. WE WILL BE TAKING
PHONE CALLS- ON THE PHONES WE
ARE AT IF YOU ARE DESIGNATED A
WITNESS FOR BILL YOU WILL SPEAK
ON THAT BILL UP TO TWO MINUTES
ONLY ON THE FINANCIAL ANALYSIS
OF THE BILL. IF YOU ARE NOT THE
DESIGNATED WITNESS WE WILL
ACCEPT YOU SEEN YOUR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION YOU'RE WITH AND IF
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A
SPECIFIC BILL. THAT IS ALL WE
WILL- EXCEPT AND IF YOU VIOLATE
THESE RULES US MORE THAN ONCE
THEN WE WILL CUT YOU OFF. WE'LL
CATCH UP THE FIRST TIME TO BUT-
WARN YOU. PERMANENTLY CUT SHOTS
JUST FOLLOW THE RULES- B. I
DON'T BELIEVE WE HAVE A QUORUM
QUITE YET SO WE WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE THE CALLING FOR
TESTIMONY IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE. FIVE
SEVEN IN THE ACCESS CODE IS TWO
FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN-
THEY CALL INFORMATION IS ALSO
ON THE DAILY FILE AND ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE YOU CAN
ALSO CALL OUR COMMITTEE IF
YOU'RE HAVING PROBLEMS WITH THE
PHONES. ALSO WANT TO NOTE WE
ALWAYS ACCEPT WRITTEN
COMMUNICATION ABOUT YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL AS WELL.
WE WILL GO THROUGH I ANTICIPATE
THAT MOST MEMBERS AT THIS POINT
YOU KNOW THAT THEY WILL YUP.
WAIT PRESENTATION- ON. SUSPENSE
CANDIDATES- IF THEY DO THAT- IN
YOUR WAITING TO HEAR THAT BILL
YOU WILL BE ABLE TO REGISTER
YOUR SUPPORTER OPPOSITION
DURING THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD AT THE END. OF TODAY'S
COMMITTEE HEARING. WITH THAT.
WE WILL START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
BEGIN WITH MISS REYES SAID SHE
HAS AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE WE
CAN'T TAKE A MOTION BECAUSE WE
ARE SUBCOMMITTEE. BUT WHEN WE
DO MISTER IF YOU HAVE A- DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
NINE WILL MODERNIZE THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION'S
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM.
BY FOCUSING INVESTMENTS IN THE
EMERGING MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
FREIGHT INDUSTRY. DEDICATE
FUNDING TO PROJECTS AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
PROVIDE THE PROPER PREFERENCES
FOR PROJECTS TO REDUCE
PARTICULATE MATTER IN OUR MOST
POLLUTED AREAS. TRANSPORTATION
EMISSIONS MAKE UP 50% OF ALL
EMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA AND ARE
THE MAIN CONTRIBUTOR TO POOR
AIR QUALITY. THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY THE
INLAND EMPIRE AND GREATER LOS
ANGELES ARE CURRENTLY
CLASSIFIED AS EXTREME NON
ATTAINMENT AREAS UNDER THE
FEDERAL CLEAN AIR ACT. MANY
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE SUCH
AS THE BAY AREA SACRAMENTO AND
SAN DIEGO. RANGE FROM MODERATE
TO SEVERE NON ATTAINMENT
CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
LEADER IN ADDRESSING AIR
QUALITY BUT IT'S CLEAR THAT
MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE. CLEANING
UP THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IS
CRITICAL TO DEMONSTRATING THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT NOT ONLY
CAN CO EXIST BUT ARE
COMPLEMENTARY TO EACH OTHER.
THIS RAISES YOU DON'T MIND I'M
GONNA- I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS WARM VERY QUICKLY
THANK YOU FOR THAT WERE
ESTABLISHED FORM THANK YOU.
GONZALEZ PRESENT BIGELOW
PRESENT CALDERON ZERO OUR HOLLY
DAVIES FONG GABRIEL. THE WORD
WAS HERE LIVING CORK ROBERT
RIVAS WEBER FRIEDMAN VACANCY
STONE VACANCY. ALL RIGHT AND
MISS REDUCES THIRTEEN EIGHTY
NINE DO I HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER STONE A SECOND BY MISTER
CALDERON WE WILL GO TO THE
LINES TO SEE IF THERE IS
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY NINE. DONNA'S BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
AT THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
THERE ARE TWO LINES AND YOU.
OUR FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM
LINE FORTY TWO. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS KIDS GOT FROM PLASTER
COUNTY AND I HISTORICALLY HAVE
OPPOSED THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
SEVEN TWO MORE LINES WITH
OPERATORS JUST ANOTHER MOMENT
THE. I AM SIXTY FIVE SIX FIVE.
NINE SIXTY FIVE- OPEN THEY'VE
DISCONNECTED WILL LINE SIXTY
ONE. YES HEATHER KELLER FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. NO
OTHER LINES INTO AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED THANK YOU DR
KIRK- AS IN THAT IT WE'RE GONNA
PUT ON CALL. THANK YOU MR S.
THANK YOU. NEXT MYSTERON MOST.
MR MRS PRESENTING ON AB. THREE
THIRTY EIGHT- ENJOY THE PAST
RECOMMENDATION I SEE A MOTION
BY MISTER CALDERON AT A SECOND
BY DOCTOR FORK. YOU MAY PROCEED
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I HAVE A BEFORE YOU
TODAY ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THREE
EIGHT. A MEASURE TO BRING
FORWARD THE VOICE OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE ON AN
ISSUE OF MISTREATMENT AND
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF A HORROR
PASSED OF THE STATE'S OWN
HISTORY. ONE THAT BROUGHT A TRI
CITIES AND GENOCIDE TO
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE. VERY
LITTLE OF CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN SLAVERY DURING THE
MISSION PERIOD IS CAPTURED IN
OUR HISTORY BOOKS SPANISH
MISSIONARIES AND THE MILITARY
SUB DUDE AND ENSLAVED
CALIFORNIA'S NATIVE AMERICANS
TO FORCED LABOR. AND DISPLACED
FAMILY MEMBERS IN THEIR QUEST
TO QUALITY COLONIZE THE ALREADY
INHABITED CALIFORNIA. A
MENTALITY THAT CARRIED FORWARD
TO THE STATE'S EARLIEST LEADERS
WITH THE FIRST GOVERNOR SETTING
PAID BOUNTIES TO FORMALISATION
IS AIDED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WHO EMBARKED ON A
DELIBERATE POLICY OF GENOCIDE.
AS DEFINED BY POST HOLOCAUST
HUMAN RIGHTS TRIBUNALS. WHAT
PANEL CENTER SERVES AS A
CONSTANT REMINDER OF THAT ERA A
VIEWING CALIFORNIA INDIANS AS
LESS THAN HUMAN. SOME ARGUE
THAT SERRA SHOULD NOT BE JUDGED
BY TODAY'S VALUES YES AS EARLY
AS FIFTEEN THIRTY THE SPANISH
KING CARLOS SAID I FOR BATES
LEVER SLAVERY DUE TO
MISTREATMENT OF INDIANS. AND IN
FIFTEEN THIRTY SEVEN PAUL PAUL
THE THIRD ISSUE AN ETIQUETTE
TRYING TO EN MASSACRES AND
SLAVE MEN OF INDIAN PEOPLES AND
AGAIN FRENCH NAVY CAPTAIN JOHN
FRANCIS THE GALA UPON ARRIVING
IN MONTEREY BAY. MONTEREY BAY
IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SIX WAS
APPALLED BY THE MISSIONARIES
ABUSE OF NATIVE AMERICANS
RIDING CORPORAL PUNISHMENT IS
INFLICTED ON THE INDIANS OF
BOTH SEXES WHO NEGLECT THE
EXERCISE OF BEAUTY AND MANY
SINS WHICH IN EUROPE ARE LEFT
TO DIVINE JUSTICE. ARE HERE IN
MONTEREY PUNISHED. BY IRONS AND
STOCKS. CITIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND EVEN SOME CATHOLIC
INSTITUTIONS. HAVE REMOVED
TRIBUTES TO SERRA IN A. TWENTY
FIFTEEN TWENTY FIFTEEN POPE
FRANCIS APOLOGIZE FOR THE MANY
GRAVE SINS COMMITTED AGAINST
THE NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE OF
AMERICA AND ASKED FOR
FORGIVENESS. YES FIFTY YEARS
HIS STATUE HAS STOOD IN THE
CAPITAL PART AS A CONSTANT
REMINDER TO THE NATIVE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA OF THE ATROCITIES
COMMITTED AGAINST THEM AND THE
HORROR TREATMENT INFLICTED UPON
THEM DURING THE SO CALLED
COLONIZATION SPANISH PERIOD.
THIS BILL WILL PAVE THE WAY FOR
THE VOICES OF THOSE WHO WERE
OPPRESSED IN SLAVE AND FORCED
TO LABOR. TO BUILD THE MISSIONS
TO ONCE AND FOR ALL HAVE A
VOICE. A VOICE THAT WILL TELL A
FACTUAL ACCOUNT OF HISTORY AND
HAS BEEN WHAT THAT HAS BEEN ONE
SIDED FOR MANY YEARS NOW IS
THAT TIME FOR THAT VOICE TO BE
HEARD. THIS BILL WILL BRING IN
A NEW ERA ONE WHERE
CALIFORNIA'S ELECTED DIRECTED
OFFICIALS TAKE ACTION TO
CORRECT THE WRONGS OF THE PAST
AND TO RECOGNIZE THE IMMENSE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PEOPLE HAVE
PAID TO THIS GREAT STATE. YEAH
THE AMOUNTS PLUS. THAT CAME
WITH IT. AB THREE THREE EIGHT
WELL AUTHORIZED THE
CONSTRUCTION OF A LONG OVERDUE
MONUMENT TO THE TRIBES TO
CONTINUE TO CALL THIS PLACE
HERE IN THE SACRAMENTO AREA
HOME IT WILL BRING A LONG
OVERDUE END TO THE MEMORIZATION
OF A MAN WHO SET FORTH THE
MENTALITY OF TREATING
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE AS
LESS THAN HUMAN. BY THE
AUTHORIZING THE CONTINUED
PRESENCE OF SIENA'S STATUTE IN
THE CAPITOL PARK. WITH ME TODAY.
IS SUPPORT IS CHAIRWOMAN REGINA
CUELLAR OF THE SHINGLE SPRINGS
RANCHERIA TRIBAL GOVERNMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER RAMOS- WE WILL
GO ISSUE I'M ASSUMING SHE'S ON
THE WITNESS I BELIEVE SO I'M ON
THE LINE- I WANT TO REMIND
FOLKS THAT THIS IS A FISCAL
COMMITTEE SO- ONLY BECAUSE I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU AS
HISTORY DID I. DO WE GET DOWN
THAT ROAD THANK YOU MR IMUS BUT
WE'RE GONNA TRY TO DO AT THIS
POINT KEEP COMMENTS TO THE
FISCAL MATTER ON THE BILL
BEGINNING WITH CHAIRWOMAN-
REGINA. WE ARE. SHE WAS ON THE
WITNESS LINE. GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY CAN YOU HEAR ME YEAH.
GOOD MORNING YOU'RE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER BIGELOW AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS REGINA
CUELLAR CHAIRMAN OF THE SHINGLE
SPRINGS BAND OF MIWOK INDIANS.
THREE THE SACRAMENTO AREA AND
PEOPLE ARE RICH IN HERITAGE
CULTURE AND TRADITION THIS AREA
WAS VIEWED AS THE FEDERAL
CONDITIONAL ECONOMIC CEREMONIAL
AND POLITICAL POWER JUST AS IT
IS TODAY. OUR TRIBE ANCESTRY
INCLUDES ANYTHING ON ME WALK
AND MIGHT BE LENIENT WHICH
DIRECTLY CONNECTS OUR COMMUNITY
TO VERY SPILLAGES AND HOMELAND
ALONG AND BETWEEN THE RIVERS IN
THIS AREA. ONE OF THE TRIBES
PRIMARY VILLAGE BY. POSITIONING
IS LOCATED AT. PRESENT DAY
DISCOVERY PARK. THE LAND WOULD
GO OFF THREE THE WHOLE OF THE-
PEOPLE WHO INJURED AND- THE
EARLY CHECK OF STAY. IN WHICH
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WAS
COMPLICIT IN AN- VIOLENCE
EXPLOITATION AND ATTEMPTED
DESTRUCTION OF TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES. HE'S COMMUNITIES
AND THE MANY TRIBAL COMMUNITIES
WITHIN CALIFORNIA HAVE REMAINED
COMMITTED TO THE STEWARDSHIP OF
THE PLANET SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF TIME AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO
SO. THE STATE CAPITOL GROUNDS
SERVICE IN AREA TO DISPLAY
VARIOUS MEMORIALS AND
MONUMENTS. HAVE WE BEEN
CONSULTED IN NINETEEN SIXTY
THREE WHAT WE WOULD HAVE SHARED
ONE OF FEDERAL DATA CRITICAL
ROLE IN THE SLAVERY AND
GENOCIDE OF OUR NATIVE AMERICAN
ANCESTORS. IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
WE HAVE THE UTMOST METRONOMY IN
DETERMINING HOW WE TELL OUR
STORY. AB THREE THREE EIGHT
WOULD AUTHORIZE TRIBAL NATIONS
IN CONSULTATION WITH THE STATE
TO PLAN CONSTRUCT AND MAINTAIN
A MONUMENT ON THE GROUNDS OF
THE STATE CAPITOL. THIS FIRST
COLLABORATIVE STEP IS CRITICAL
TO ENSURE APPROVAL. AB THREE
THREE IS A GREAT FIRST STEP IN
A LONG PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT
NATIVE AMERICAN VOICES ARE
HEARD. THE TIME IS RIGHT TO
ERECT A MONUMENT THAT PROPERLY
REPRESENTS OUR CULTURAL
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THIS REGION.
SHINGLE SPRINGS BAND OF MIWOK
INDIANS IS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB THREE THREE EIGHT. THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING
US TO SHARE OUR TESTIMONY TODAY
AND WE THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RONALD FOR BRINGING AB. THREE
THREE FORWARD. THANK YOU FOR
NOW THOUGH- I SEE NOBODY. IN OP
AS A WITNESS WE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES IF YOU'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB THREE THREE
EIGHT NOW IS THE TIME OPERATOR.
YOU TO STATE YOUR POSITION ON
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
AGAIN THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO THE STATE YOUR POSITION ON
AB THREE THREE EIGHT. WE'LL GO
TO LINE EIGHTY EIGHT ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES HELLO YES I
OPPOSE THE BILL JUST BECAUSE
YOU CAN'T REPEAT I THANK YOU
THANK YOU. I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE THE PHONE LINES NOW
PEOPLE CAN STATE THEIR NAME
THEIR ORGANIZATION IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION AND THAT IS ALL.
NEXT WE HAVE LINE ELEVEN. LINE
ELEVEN I'M CALLING IT IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION YOU DID
NOT HAVE A PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING TO BE THAT WITNESS
THE- AND THAT AND THAT- THE
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION HAS BE
REGISTERED BEFORE THE MEETING
TO BE ON A WITNESS LINE SO WE
DIDN'T HAVE OPPOSITION I'M
REQUESTED TO TESTIFY AND SO WE
ARE JUST TAKING IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WITH YOUR NAME.
ORGANIZATION IF YOU HAVE ONE IN
YOUR POSITION. BINA. FORTY TWO
FOUR TWO. MY NAME IS KIM SCOTT
FROM PLASTER COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU
EIGHTY THREE THREE EIGHT THANK
YOU. THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES
AND CURATORS TAR. THANK YOU-
THAT A TICKET BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE I SEE NO QUESTIONS OF
MISTER BIGELOW ON. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND TO THE AUTHOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TODAY FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION RECOGNIZED-
TODAY THE REPUBLICANS WON'T BE
VOTING ON THIS BILL BUT WE
APPRECIATE AND RESPECT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE THE
DIALOGUE WITH YOU. AND THE
POSITION IS CLEAR IT'S JUST ON
THE FISCAL SIDE THAT'S WHY
WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS YOU HEARD
THE CHAIR- SPEAK TO THAT FACT
THIS IS A PHYSICAL COMMITTEE
NOT A POLICY SITES SO WE'RE NOT
REFLECTING ON THE POLICY WERE
REFLECTING ON. THE FISCAL SIDE
SO I APPRECIATE THE CHECK- THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE THE
DIALOGUE AND COUNSEL WITH YOU
TO WORK ON. THIS BILL AS IT
MOVES FORWARD. THANK YOU I WILL
NOTE THAT- THERE THERE IS NO
FISCAL CSTS THAT THE- RIGHT
NOW IN THIS BILL- THIS IS GOING
TO BE FUNDED BY THE-
GENEROSITY. OF OUR TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS- I WILL NOTE THAT-
IT IS UNFORTUNATE THAT THE
FISCAL WAS STRIPPED OUT OF THIS
BILL- THERE SHOULD BE IT SHOULD
BE AFFORDED THE SAME RESPECT.
OF UPKEEP AND CLEANING- THAT
THE FORMER. HOPEFULLY FORMER
STATUTE DEAD AND SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THAT IN SOME
OTHER FORM PERHAPS- THROUGH THE
BUDGET. IN ORDER TO GIVE IT IF
THEY DO RESPECT IT DESERVES SO
WITH THAT- MR ALMOST ALL TAKE
THAT AS YOUR CLOTHES. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIRMAN MR VICE CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR THAT AS YESTERDAY
WE DISCUSSED IT WE'RE ALWAYS
OPEN TO DIALOGUE AND TALK ABOUT
THESE ISSUES AND EVEN OFFERED
LAST NIGHT TO CONTINUE TO. WORK
LATE INTO THE NIGHT WITH
YOURSELF SO WE'RE ALWAYS OPEN
TO CONTINUE TO WORK IN THE
FURTHER- THE ISSUES THAT ARE
FACING CALIFORNIA'S SHEEPLE. SO
IN CLOSING THIS BILL IS ABOUT
RESPECT AS THE VERY ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT THAT WE ALL REPRESENT
HAVE THESE ATROCITIES HAPPENED
IN OUR OWN AREAS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND AS A STATE
LEGISLATURE WE SHOULD NOT SHY
AWAY. BUT WE SHOULD STAND AS
ONE SO THAT THE VOICE THAT HAS
YET TO BE HEARD. CONTINUES TO
BE HEARD IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE IN SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE. THANK
THANK YOU MR ALMOST- THAT GETS
OUT WITH- THE REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING THANK YOU I ALSO CAN
ANNOUNCE IT AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
NINE BY MISCREANTS GOT OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL WITH MR FONG
VOTING HI. STARTING OFF STRONG-
THANK YOU AND WE WILL GO NOW TO
MISTER COOPER I WANT TO REMIND
FOLKS- I GOTTA BE HONEST WE
ALLOW THAT TO GO FORWARD
BECAUSE I THINK WE CAN ALL USE
A LITTLE EXTRA HISTORY- THAT
WAS DENIED TO US FOR TOO LONG
AND SO I ALLOWED A MISTER RAMOS
SOME LEEWAY WE THIS IS A FISCAL
COMMUTE. COMMITTEE WE FROM HERE
ON OUT WILL ONLY TAKE FISCAL
TESTIMONY- WITHOUT MISTER
COOPER IF YOU'D LIKE TO PRESENT
ON- AB THREE EIGHTY SIX I SEE
IN MOTION BY. MISS CARILLO IN A
SECOND BY DOCTOR CORK. THE
MANAGER COLLEAGUES A. B. THREE
SIX WILL CREATE A PUBLIC
RECORDS DISCLOSURE STRUCTURE
THAT ALLOW CALPERS TO PURSUE
INVESTMENTS IN THE PRIVATE LOW
MARKET. AB THREE EIGHTY SIX
STRIKES THE RIGHT BALANCE
BETWEEN THE CONFIDENTIALITY.
NECESSARY FOR BORROWERS IN THE
TRANSPARENCY THE CARD OF A
PUBLIC PENSION SYSTEM. AB THREE
SIX HAS NO ADDITIONAL STATE
COST. THANK YOU FOR. THANK YOU
MISTER COOPER- WE WILL GO AND I
SEE NO REGISTERED- WITNESSES WE
WILL GO TO SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE EIGHTY
SIX ON THE PHONE LINES NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. YOU
TO STATE YOUR POSITION ON THIS
BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE AGAIN
THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO. THE
FIRST LINE FORTY TWO. MY NAME
IS KIM SCOTT FROM FOSTER CANDY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY
THREE EIGHTY SIX. THANK YOU. OF
LINE ELEVEN. I STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB THREE EIGHTY SIX AND EVERY
THING ABOUT JIM COOPER OKAY
THANK YOU. I THINK OUR. TWENTY
NINE NINETY EIGHT. THIS IS
ANDREW WHITE BUT THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT
SYSTEM OF THE SPONSORED STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE SIXTY
ONE. SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MOVIELINE. EIGHTY EIGHT
ZERO. YEAH HI MY NAME IS
SHANNON HEIL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU. M.
LINE ONE ALL ONE. I'M SURE
MEMBERS BACKGROUND WITH THE
RETIRED PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOUNG. AND
LINE ONE OH TWO. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS CHRISTINA I'M
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
WILL TAKE IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE I SEE NO QUESTION
THAT GETS OUT OF THE WORLD- I'M
SO SORRY MISS DAVIES IN
QUESTION NO FROM JUST JUST A
QUICK COMMENT I MADE I
SUPPORTED FURTHERING THE
CONVERSATION WITH STAKEHOLDERS
IN JUDICIARY BUT AFTER TALKING
TO OTHER STAKEHOLDERS I JUST
CAN'T SUPPORT THIS BILL ANYMORE
JUST DUE TO LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY WHEN IT COMES TO
USING TAXPAYERS DOLLARS. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WITH THAT. GETS
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL WITH MR
GABRIEL NOT VOTING THANK YOU
MISTER COOPER. MR CHANNEL.
MISTER CHANNELS LIKE YOU'RE
PRESENTING ON AB TWELVE SIXTY
HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW
AND A SECOND BY MISS DAVIES-
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MOVE TIME
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU WITH THAT WILL GO TO THE
TELEPHONE SINCERE NO- WITNESSES
REGISTERED WE WILL SAY SUPPORT
OR OPPOSE ONLY ON AB TWELVE
SIXTY. THE STATE YOUR POSITION
AS BUILDING A PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE MIN ZERO
AT THIS TIME ME JUST A MOMENT
PLEASE. NINE TWENTY NINE. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR NUMBERS
DELANEY HUNTER ON BEHALF THE
SAN BERNARD DINO CAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY WE ARE
THE SPONSOR AND URGENT I FELT.
THANK YOU. NO OTHER LINES IN Q.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT I SEE NO
QUESTIONS LIKE IT'S OUT ON A
ROLL CALL MR TEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM- DOCTOR RANDY
LAST. IS YOU CAN YOU CAN REPEAT
MR CHANCE PERFECT PERFORMANCE
WITH AB THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR I
SEE A MOTION BY DOCTOR QUIRK A
SECOND PLAY- MISS FRIEDMAN. YOU
MAY PER CENT I WILL FOLLOW IN
HIS LEAD IN THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
ANOTHER. THIS IS HOW WE GET
THROUGH TWO HUNDRED FORTY TWO
VOTES. ALL RIGHT- WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO A WITNESS ON THE
PHONE- MERRY'S SILAS. I THINK
IS YOUR WITNESS SHE MIGHT BE
HERE JUST TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
THAT'S CORRECT. MARICELA I AM-
HAPPY TO SUPPORT AB THIRTEEN
FORTY FOUR ABOUT A CO SPONSOR
OF THE BILL AS WELL- I'M WITH
THE DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE. ALSO
WE HAVE THE NATIONAL HARM
REDUCTION COALITION. UPDATION
THE BILL WILL PAY MONEY TO.
THING TO DO BOTH BECAUSE YOU'RE
IN FROM ARE CAUGHT SAVING FOR
THE- BAKER VETERANS OF DISEASES
THAT ARE EXTREMELY COSTLY TO
TREAT. AND THE COST LARGELY
FALLEN MEDIC ALLEN EIGHT OUT
THEY ALSO PREVENT OVERDOSE
DEATH COSTS ARE EMERGENCY. AND
HOSPITAL. FURTHER OUT OF THE
CAR IN THE STATE AND FEDERAL.
CAN CONDUCT PEOPLE REFUSE IN
ORDER TO PUBLIC HEALTH FOR AS
THE AS A NON. WASTE OF FARM. SO
I THINK DOCTOR AND ELECTRICAL
THE FORGET IT COST SAVING. AND
AFTER I THE. THANK YOU WILL GO
TO LINES ANYWAY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB THREE FORTY
FOUR. THANK YOUR POSITION
PRESSING ONE THEN. USING YOUR
ME PRESS ONE THEN. WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE FORTY TWO MINUS
OPEN. MY NAME IS KEN STARR FROM
GLOUCESTER COUNTY FIVE STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB ONE THREE FOUR FOUR
THANK YOU. BUT LINE SIXTY ONE.
HELLO THIS IS HEATHER KELLER
FROM SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ONE THREE
FOUR FOUR. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
LINE. EIGHTY EIGHT ZERO. THE
VISION AND HOW SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE BILL. THANK YOU. THERE ARE
NO FOR THE LINES INTO AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE I SEE NO
QUESTION- MR BIGELOW THANK YOU
FOR THE AUTHORED YOU HEARD
SEVERAL OF THE COUNTY'S COME
ONLINE I KNOW I'VE RECEIVED A
NUMBER OF CALLS FROM COUNTIES-
FROM THE RC RC WORLD IN FROM
THE S. C. SACK WORLD ALL
RAISING CONCERNS WITH RESPECT
TO. NEEDLES BEING EXCHANGED BUT
THERE'S A PROBLEM WHEN THAT
HAPPENS IT THEY GET LEFT OUT
AND KIDS GET EXPOSED TO A WOMAN
WE OFTEN TIMES HAVE SEEN IN THE
PAST FOR THESE MEALS ARE LEFT
CLOSE TO OUR SCHOOLS THERE ARE
LEFT TO AREAS THAT WE KNOW
COULD CAUSE. ISSUES SO HOW DO
YOU ADDRESS THAT CONCERN THAT'S
BEING RAISED- CURRENTLY THE
BILL WAS BIFURCATED IN AN
INITIAL COMMITTEE HEARING AT
THAT TIME A NUISANCE PROVISION
IS STILL AVAILABLE FOR. LOCALS
IF THEY WISHED TO PURSUE THAT
OPTION. OKAY SO UNDER THE
NUISANCE AND THEN WITH RESPECT
TO THE SEQUEL- ACTION HOW DO
YOU ADDRESS THAT PARTICULAR
ISSUE THAT THEY'RE RAISING
SHOULDN'T THIS BE A SEQUEL
PROCESS- WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE
ACTION RIGHT NOW WE ARE-
CONCERNS THAT THESE PUBLIC
HEALTH PREVENTION SERVICES WILL
BE CURTAILED AT THE EXACT TIME
IN WHICH THEY ARE NEEDED. IN
THE MIDST OF A PANDEMIC IN
WHICH WE ARE HAVING AN OPIOID
CRISIS THESE ARE THE TIMES WHEN
THE S. C. PEAS ARE NEEDED MORE
THAN EVER. OKAY. I THINK I'LL
JUST WAIT TO GO THERE- I THINK
THE REAL ISSUE FOR US IS THE
FACT THAT OUR LOCAL COUNTIES
WHO WERE ENTRUSTED WITH
ADMINISTERING YOUR PROPOSED LAW
ARE FINDING CHALLENGE WITH THE
ABILITY TO DO THAT. IN A SAFE
WAY SO. UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO HELP SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY I UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH SO. THANK YOU I SEE
NO OTHER COMMENTS- ED DOCTRINE
BILL I DON'T USUALLY LOVE
SEQUENCE EMPTIONS I DON'T EVEN
USUALLY LIKE THEM BUT THIS IS
ONE THAT I FULLY SUPPORT SO-
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD IT BACK IT'S HOW TO BE
ROLL CALL WITH MISTER CALDERON
UPLOADING. ALL RIGHT- I HAD IN
I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS
ACCURATE I HAVE MISSED RIVAS
NEXTER. MYSTERIES I MIGHT BE
MISTAKEN THAT I HAVE YOU
PRESENTING TO BILLS WILL GO
FIRST WITH THE ONE THAT MAKES
SENSE AB TEN FORTY THREE AND
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
YOU HAVE TO PRESENT ON THAT
ONE- I SEE A MOTION OF BY DR
QUIRK. AS SECOND. BY DR DOT
MISS DR WEBER THE- AND- YOU MAY
PROCEED ON TEN FORTY THREE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB TEN FORTY THREE IS
SPONSORED BY L. A. COUNTY AND
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY I WOULD
LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO AMY
BIOTECH DIRECTOR OF THE LA
DEPARTMENT OF REGIONAL
PLANNING. PERFECT THANK YOU THE
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE I THINK
WE HAVE TO. OPERATOR. DO WE
HAVE A WITNESS ON THE JURY
DETERMINED. COULD YOU TELL ME
THE SECOND NAME OTHER THAN.
THAT AND THE FAITH CONLEY IS
WHAT I HAVE. I DO APOLOGIZE I
pTHIS TIME THAT'S FINE WE CAN GO
ON TO SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF
AB TEN FORTY THREE JUST
REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. STATE YOUR POSITION
ON THIS BILL AB TEN FORTY THREE
NEW PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
AGAIN THAT'S ONE ZERO. WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE ONE ELEVEN. WELL.
ONE ELEVEN A LINE IS OPEN. HI
I'M CALLING IN STRONG
OPPOSITION AND I WOULD BE
ARAMBULA BILL I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU WE I WANT TO REMIND FOLKS-
YOU CAN STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION IF YOU'RE
AFFILIATED WITH ONE AND YOUR
POSITION AND THAT'S IT IF NOT
YOU WILL BE. DISCONNECTED THANK
YOU. NINE FIFTY THREE. GOOD
MORNING THE SHERIN REPORT WITH
THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NINE SIXTY NINE. CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT OF AB TEN FORTY THREE
THANK. THANK YOU. LINE FORTY
TWO. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
KIM SCOTT FROM GLOUCESTER
COUNTY HAS PROBABLY OPPOSE AB
ONE ZERO FOUR THREE. THANK YOU.
LINE SIXTY ONE. HI THIS IS
HEATHER KELLER FROM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
ONE ZERO FOUR THREE THANK YOU.
OR LINE LINE EIGHTY. YES THE
SHANNON HOW FROM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY IN A STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
BILL. THANK YOU. NO OTHER LINES
IN Q. THANK YOU WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM. I
SEE NO COMMENTS. MISTER BEST
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. CHECK IT OUT- ONE OF THE
ROLL CALL THANK YOU. NOW ARE
YOU GONNA PRESENT ON A SUSPENSE
FILM YES I HAVE AB SEVENTY ONE.
OKAY CAN I GO AHEAD YOU SURE
CAN THANK YOU SO GOOD MORNING
MADAM TURN MEMBERS AB SEVENTY
ONE ESTABLISHES FOR THE FIRST
TIME EVER AN ONGOING SOURCE OF
STATE FUNDING FOR LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS TO HOMELESSNESS. I'M
INCREDIBLY THANKFUL TO HAVE
JACQUI BOW BURKE FROM THE
PATRIOTIC MILLIONAIRES
PROVIDING TESTIMONY. THANK YOU
FOR THE PRE PRESENTATION WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES- FOR OUR
TEST MONEY FROM JACQUI BELL
BURKE. THANK YOU CAN YOU HEAR
ME YEP. OKAY THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
SICK J. GOLDBERG AND I'M A
MEMBER OF THE PATRIOTIC
MILLIONAIRES ORGANIZATION OF
WEALTHY INDIVIDUALS WHO SHARE A
PROFOUND CONCERN TO THE
ESCALATING LEVELS IN EQUITY IN
OUR COUNTRY. I'M HERE TODAY TO
URGE CALIFORNIA LEADERS TO
SUPPORT AB SEVENTY ONE AND TAX
OF WEALTHIEST CORPORATIONS SO
WE CAN BEGIN TO ADDRESS AND
SHALL BE OUT OF CONTROL
INEQUITIES THAT HAVE LED TO THE
ALARMING NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
FACING HOMELESSNESS AND HOW
GREAT STATE BY TAXING
CALIFORNIA'S WEALTHIEST
CORPORATIONS WE CAN ENSURE THAT
THEY PAID THE TAXES THEY OWE.
IN CALIFORNIA EVEN WHEN THEY
ATTEMPT TO SHIFT THE TOPIC TO
TAX. HAVENS AROUND THE GLOBE.
THESE COOPERATE BY IMMENSELY
FROM THE- WORK FOR AND COST
BASE POWER. IT'S ABOUT TIME
THEY PAY FAIR. FOR THE PAST FEW
YEARS CORPORATE HAVE PROPER
TREATMENT BEYOND THAT WATER
STREAMS THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
GOP TAX CUTS SLASH THE FEDERAL
CORPORATE TAX RATE FROM 35% TO
TWENTY ONE. AND EXPANDED A
NUMBER OF LOOPHOLES HAVING A
WEALTHY CORPORATIONS A WINDFALL
OF NEARLY ONE BILLION DOLLARS
PER YEAR WHAT SOME SKEPTICS
CLAIM THAT RAISING CORPORATE
TAXES WILL COLD TO BUSINESSES
TO TREAT THE STATE THESE
CONCERNS ARE UNFOUNDED
CALIFORNIA'S CORPORATE TAX IS
INTRACTABLE. CORPORATIONS DOING
BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA. ALL
LOCATION OKAY SO THE MORE IT'S
NO WEALTHY INDIVIDUALS AND
CORPORATIONS LEAVING CALIFORNIA
RATHER IT'S CRITICAL AND MIDDLE
INCOME WORKERS WHO CANNOT
AFFORD TO LIVE. HERE IN THE
STATE ANYMORE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE- BUT TO SEE. THANK YOU
DO WE ALSO HAVE A SET WITNESS.
ON THE BROWN'S MARGOT KUSHEL I
BELIEVE SO. HI THANK YOU SO
MUCH TERRY MY NAME IS HECTOR
MARC OKAY SHALL I'M A PROFESSOR
OF MEDICINE AT UCSF RIGHT
DIRECTED MANY OF HOMELESSNESS
AND HOUSING INITIATIVE WHEN YOU
CONSIDER THE COST OF THE SALE I
ASK YOU TO CONSIDER THE COST OF
INACTION HOMELESSNESS TO LEAD
TO HIGHER RATES OF PREVENTABLE
YOU CAN EMERGENCY SERVICES
HOSPITALIZATION AND NURSING
HOME CARE HE'S CONFIDENT ON THE
BERGEN ON MEDIC CAL AD LOCAL
HELICOPTER. IS RETIRING THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC
HOMELESSNESS IN OVERCROWDED.
THE NERVOUS KOPPERT MANAGING
THE PANDEMIC AND IT'S
DEVASTATING HUMAN AND FINANCIAL
TOLL MANAGING RATHER THAN
SOMETHING PUBLIC WITH ****
MONEY NOT ONLY IN HIGH HELP
CALL BUT IT INCREASED COSTS TO
POLICING SANITATION TO PREVENT
THE SYSTEM AND OTHER HOME OF
HIS EXACT ENORMOUS ALL OF THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY TO DECREASES
IN TOWARDS AND DECREASED BUT
TRAFFIC LEADING TO A LOSS OF
TAX REVENUE FOR THE STATE. HOME
OF THE TICKETING HOW THE COST
TO MAKE IT VERY SAID WORKING
HEALTH THE MENTAL HEALTH AND
LEADING TO EARLY MORTALITY
THERE IS NO RISK TO HEALTH AND
SAFETY IS PROFOUND OF SOME OF
THAT WE KNOW HOW TO SOLVE THIS
CRISIS IT IS CAUSED BY THE DIRE
LACK OF HOUSING FOR EXTREMELY
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE ONLY TWENTY
FOUR UNITS OF HOUSING AVAILABLE
PORTABLE FOR EVERY A HUNDRED
EXTRA ME LOVE COME HOUSEHOLDS.
FROM HIGH QUALITY EVIDENCE WE
KNOW THAT HOUSING FIRST WORK
PROVIDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WITHOUT PRECONDITIONS TO THOSE
WHO ARE HOMELESS PEOPLE WITH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DISABILITIES
WE NEED TO PROVIDE THAT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WITH
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES THAT WE
NEED TO PROVIDE ONGOING
SUBSIDIES TO ALLOW THAT HAVING
TO REMAIN AFFORDABLE WE NEED TO
FOCUS NOT ONLY ON THOSE WHO ARE
HOMELESS CURRENTLY BUT WE MUST
EXPAND EVIDENCE BASED EFFORTS
TO PREVENT SOME OF THAT. AB
SEVENTY ONE WOULD PREVENT BUT
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES TO BRING
THE SOLUTION TO SCALE AS A
PHYSICIAN AND RESEARCHER I CAN
TELL YOU THERE IS NO GREATER
THREAT TO HOME HEALTH AND
HOMELESSNESS HOMELESSNESS WITH
THE UNCLE TOTAL COSTS AND AB.
SEVENTY ONE WHICH IS WELL
DESIGNED TO ADDRESS. THERE IS
NO MEDICINE AT PARKLAND HIGH.
THANK YOU FOR AND I ME. THANK
YOU SO MUCH WHENEVER THE PHONE
LINE. IS ANY SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO. SO ONE EIGHTY
BILL THAT IS BEING MOVED TO
SYSTEM FILE. THE STATE YOUR
POSITION ON AB SEVENTY ONE YOUR
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. LOCAL
FIRST ONLINE FIFTY THREE. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS SHERIN REPORT
ON BEHALF OF THE CORPORATION
FOR SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND THE
GREEN CALIFORNIA HOME
PROHIBITION WE ARE CO SPONSORS-
AB SEVENTY ONE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. LINE. SEVENTY EIGHT.
MORE THAN THAT IN TURN MEMBERS
TO BRING OUT THE FACILITY RIGHT
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ONE OH NINE. GOOD
MORNING JUST HIRE ME HALF THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
WE MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOUNG.
EIGHTY EIGHTY EIGHT. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR CHRIS WHITE
SAKE WITH WESTERN MANUFACTURED
HOUSING COMMUNITY
DISASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WEHRLEIN SIXTY NINE. SECOND
AMERICA WE HAVE A HOUSING
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU. LINE.
ONE EIGHTEEN. GOOD MORNING AND
I'M SURE MEMBERS MARKET%
GUERRERO REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS CO SPONSORED THE
BILL WE URGE- YOUR SUPPORT FOR
PASSAGE THE BLOOD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LIONEL ONE ELEVEN.
YOU HAVE NO PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION THIS BILL IS NOT
GETTING EQUAL THANK YOUNG. JUST
MY NAME AGAIN YOUR VISIT YOUR
EMAIL PLEASE. THANK. NINE SIXTY
ONE. HEATHER KELLER FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB SEVENTY ONE
THANK YOU. ONE NINETEEN. THANK
YOU MODERATOR MEDICARE MEMBERS
WITH MANY GERMANS MET YOUR
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
SUPPORT. LINE. SEVENTY SEVEN
ZERO. GOOD MORNING SHARE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
DOESN'T WANT TO BE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION EIGHTY SEVENTY ONE
THANK YOU. ONE OF OR. THIS IS
MORE TODAY NO GAP THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURING
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION RESPECT
OPPOSITION AB SEVENTY ONE OF
THE MANUFACTURER THANK. LINE.
FORTY TWO. CAN FROM WALKER
COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
SEVENTY ONE THANK YOUNG. BY
BUYING. SIXTY SIX. DURI ON
BEHALF OF INDIVISIBLE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
ONE TWENTY THREE ONE TWO THREE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
SERVICES ON THE RESTAURANT ALSO
BEHALF OF PUBLIC ADVOCATE SPOT
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE.
EIGHTY EIGHT ZERO. THIS IS
SHANNON HEIL AND I AM IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL THAT
WILL CRUSH CALIFORNIA MORE
THANK YOU. ONE TWENTY SIX. ST
LOS ANGELES IS STRONG STRONG
SUPPORT AB SEVENTY ONE THANK
YOU. ONE TWENTY SEVEN. BEN
MORNING MADAM CHAIR NUMBER
MODELING COOPER FROM THE OPEN
MARKET BEHALF OF PUNCHES OFF
THE COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE ONE TWENTY
EIGHT. PRESIDENT YOUNG FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINES IN
Q. THANK YOU- WITH THAT WE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
I SEE NO COMMENTS THAT GETS
MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE
THANK YOU MISTER DAVIS THANK
YOU. ADMITTED GO AHEAD AND COME
UP MISS WICKS- THIS WICKS. IS
IT I HAVE. IS YOUR NAME ON THE
BILL NOW I'M PRESENT AND NOT
YET SEVEN MINUTES FOR BOTH
WEEKS IS PRESENT TEEN- A BILL
THAT WAS ORIGINALLY AUTHORED BY
MR BONTA SHE IS REPLACING HER
NAME ON THE BILL SO- IT ENJOYS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION IT IS
AB FOUR FIFTY FIVE- WE HAVE A-
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO. A
SECOND BY MR STONE- YOU MAY
PROCEED MISS REX THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AB FOUR
FIFTY FIVE WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
BARE TOOL THIRTY IN
CONSULTATION WITH CALTRANS TO
ESTABLISH A TRAFFIC ONLY SORRY
TRANSIT ONLY TRAVELING ON THE
BEVERAGE QUARTER DURING PEAK
HOURS. WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY
VERY BRIEFLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IS JONATHAN CASPER'S
TRANSPORTATION POLICY MANAGER
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ITEM.
THANK YOU JONATHAN. HI I'M JUST
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION THE PHONE
LINES ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB FOR FIFTY FIVE.
STATE YOUR POSITION THERE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN FOR
AB FOUR FIFTY FIVE THAT'S ONE
THEN ZERO PLEASE. WELL FIRST
ONLINE ONE ONLY. GOOD MORNING
JUST KEEP ON COMING UP WITH
ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT
DISTRICT AND CATCH EDUCATION
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE ONE OH NINE.
GOOD MORNING JUST PRIOR TO
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR FIVE FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE.
FORTY TWO. WALKER COUNTY OPPOSE
AB FOUR FIVE FIVE THANK YOU.
NINE SIXTY ONE. HEATHER KELLER
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY FOUR
FIVE FIVE. LINE ONE ELEVEN.
EACH ADDRESS HELLO LORRAINE I.
FOUR FIVE FIVE THANK YOU. THERE
ARE NO OTHER LINES IN Q. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE I SEE NO
COMMENTS BACK IT'S OUT ON A- A
ROLL CALL NOW WITH THE RECENT
PHONE. A BIG ROLE HOW WITH M.
S. DAVIES MR FONG NOT VOTING
THANK YOU I COULDN'T FIND IT
BECAUSE IT WAS UNDER BONTA
THANK YOU. I THINK ERA. ALRIGHT
MR LEVY MISTER LEE'S PRESENTING
ON AB THIRTEEN THIRTY SEVEN I
WANT TO REMIND PEOPLE WE HAVE
TWO HUNDRED FORTY TWO BILLS SO-
WE'D LIKE. TO GET OUT OF HERE
TODAY. TWENTY MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AB THIRTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN EXTENDS BARKS EXISTING
AUTHORITY ISSUED PROHIBITION
ORDERS TO THE TWO NEW SANTA
CLARA COUNTY STATIONS IN MY
DISTRICT WHICH OPENED LAST
SUMMER. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
WITH ME AS A MAN TO CRUISE THE
RELATIONS AT PARK AND RESPECT
APPS FOR YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU
THAT'S THE WAY IT'S DONE-
AMANDA IS JOHN THE LINE. YES
GOOD MORNING- AMANDA GROUP WITH
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
RAPID TRANSIT DISTRICT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID THE BILL
WOULD MANDATE FIFTEEN LAW
REGARDING THE ISSUANCE OF
TRANSIT PROBATION ORDERS. AREAS
IN PROPERTY IN WHICH A TRANSIT
DISTRICT DOES NOT OWN BUT IS
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT SERVICES PURSUANT
TO AN INTERAGENCY AGREEMENT.
THE BILL DID NOT CREATE A NEW
CRIME AND IS NOT INTENDED TO
LEAD TO MORE ARRESTS OR
MISDEMEANOR CHARGES. THERE NO
DIRECT COSTS IN THE STATE IN
THIS BILL WOULD SIMPLY ALIGN
PART EXISTING PROBATION ORDER
ACCORDING AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES WITH THE AREAS IN
WHICH WE ALREADY ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR POLICING THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
OTHER SPEAKERS ARE OPPOSITION
WHEN REGISTRY YOUR SUPPORT OR.
OPPOSITION AB THIRTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN. TO SPEAK ON AB THIRTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE'LL GO TO
LINE EIGHTY EIGHT ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE PLAYOFFS. THANK YOU IT
WOULD HAVE LINE SIXTY SIX. I'M
SORRY MANAGER GO AHEAD I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE PEOPLE ACTUALLY
SAY THEIR NAME AN ORGANIZATION
OR JUST THEIR NAME AT LEAST IF
THEY WANT TO REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU LINE SIXTY ONE. HEATHER
KELLER SACRAMENTO COUNTY-
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU. LINE.
FORTY TWO. ABOUT THE AUTHOR
COUNTY CLOSED. EIGHTY THIRTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU. LINE
ONE ELEVEN. HI LORRAINE ED
FOUNDRY HAD STRUM AND I HATE
COMMUNISM. NO OTHER LINE FIGURE
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU WE HAVE
A MOTION BY MISTER STONE A
SECOND TIME IS CARILLO. A BRING
IT BACK I SEE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MR LEE THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO GO I KNOW
THEIR NUMBER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PRESENTING FOR OTHER MEMBERS-
SO WE WILL TRY THAT WE'LL START
WITH- MR GARCIA YOU'RE
PRESENTING MR HOLDEN'S BILLS-
BOTH OF THEM WE'LL START WITH
EIGHTY SIX FORTY ONE ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE
A MOTION BY MISTER SO ON A
SECOND BY MISCREANT YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU THIS BILL
REQUIRES LOCAL. PUBLICLY OWNED
ELECTRIC UTILITIES TO DEVELOP
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION
PLANS TO SUPPORT STATES GOLD.
PUT IN AT LEAST FIVE MILLION.
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES ON THE
ROAD BY TWENTY THIRTY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
APPLE. THANK YOU I WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES TO ENSURE YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO MR
HOLDEN SAID AB. SIX FORTY ONE.
ME PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. LOCAL FIRS CLIENT. ONE
FOURTEEN ONE ONE FOUR. AND ONE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WILL MOVE ON THE LINE FORTY TWO.
K. WITH CLUSTER COUNTY ARE
STRONGLY. BILL THANK YOUNG.
WELL LINE SIXTY ONE. HEATHER
TAYLOR SACRAMENTO COUNTY
OPPOSED SIX FORTY ONE THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINE I'M
SORRY THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES
IN Q. THANK YOU. THAT GETS OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL WITH- MISS
DAVIES MR FONG NOT VOTING. YOU
CAN NOW PRESENT ON MR HOLDEN AB
TWELVE NINETY SEVEN I HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER STONE A SECOND
BY MISS KOREA. THANK YOU
MANAGER THIS BILL SEEKS TO
CLARIFY APPLICATION OF THE TERM
HOUSING WITHIN THE AYE BANK OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU. WE A WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN I MR HOLDEN. PRESS ONE
MIN ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT
WE'LL GO TO LINE FORTY TWO. CAN
WITH WATER COUNTY I FIRMLY
OPPOSE THE BILL. THEY HAVE LINE
SIXTY ONE. OTHER TELLER
SACRAMENTO COUNTY FINALLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. HELP LINE ONE
A LOT OF AN- IT FOUNDER AND I
STILL HATE COMMUNISM. I DON'T.
THINK WE HAVE LINE. EIGHTY
HOUSING SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
ALSO HATE COMMUNISM AND OPPOSED
THE SALE YOU KNOW. NO OTHER
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU AT THAT
DOES GET OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
WITH MR FONG VOTING I. THANKYOU
MR GARCIA DR QUIRK I THINK
YOU'LL BE CAN. ANY FOR MR
MULLIN AB TEN TWENTY NINE
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
OF A MOTION BY MISTER STONE A
SECOND BY MISS CARILLO YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
THIS BILL IS ABOUT AFFORDABLE
UNITS WHICH ARE NOW GOING ON TO
THE OPEN MARKET. IT WOULD ALLOW
THOSE UNITS TO BE CONSIDERED AS
SUPPORTING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SO THEY WOULD BE OPEN TO THE
CURRENT GRANTS THE COST IS
EIGHTY SEVEN THOUSAND A YEAR
FOR TWO YEARS- I WILL TURN THIS
OVER TO SUPPORT THE SUPPORT
WITNESSES WHO WILL BE VERY VERY
BRIEF. THANK YOU. SCHERING
GONZALEZ. YES GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HEARING GONZALEZ WITH
THE RUNNING PUBLIC POLICY GROUP
HAS DEFINED KIDDING ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF FOSTER CITY IN
THINKING TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK FOR PRESENTING AT TEN
TWENTY NINE TODAY BY ADDING A
PRESERVATION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS TO THE LIST OF
PRO HOUSING LOCAL POLICIES THE
CITY WILL BE IN A BETTER
POSITION TO COMPETE FOR FACTOR
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM
IN AN EFFORT TO SECURE A LONG
TERM FUNDING SOURCE. FOR
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS WERE BELOW
MARKET RATE COVENANTS ARE SET
TO EXPIRE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
NINE THIS LEGISLATURE PASSED A
BILL IN A WINE WHICH DIRECTED
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO
DESIGNATE BY EMERGENCY
REGULATION A LIST OF PRO
HOUSING JURISDICTION BY JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE SHE
RECEIVED PRIORITY FOR STATE.
FUNDING- HOUSING FOR IS AN
IMPORTANT IN AND THE HOUSING
CRISIS IN OUR STATE-
PRESERVATION OF EXISTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS IS AN
EQUALLY IMPORTANT COMPONENT IN
ENSURING OUR MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS ARE NOT DISPLACED AND
POTENTIALLY HOMELESS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU.
OKAY THE PHONE LINES IS THERE
ANY OTHER REGISTERED SUPPORT
OPPOSITION TO AB TEN TWENTY
NINE. OKAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. YOUR AVAILABLE
LINE EIGHTY EIGHT ZERO. THIS IS
SHANNON HEIL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
LINE SIXTY ONE. HEATHER KELLER
SACRAMENTO COUNTY STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
LINE. FORTY TWO. YOU WANT TO
COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TEN
TWENTY. THANK YOU. NINE ONE
ELEVEN. ANDREA YOU KNOW WHAT I
THINK THANK YOU. WE HAVE ONE
MORE LINE PENDING JUST A MOMENT
PLEASE. SHE REALLY NEEDS. ARE
WE WAITING ON ONE MORE LINE. TO
NOW WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY
FIVE. HI THIS IS- STEFFI LOOS
AS IN L. A. COUNTY I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSING THE SALE
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE ONE
TWENTY NINE. YEAH I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB WELL FIVE OH NINE.
MESSAGES FROM CHINO HILLS THANK
YOU THANK YOU. WE KNOW FOR THE
MINDS IN GEAR THANK YOU AND IF
PEOPLE THAT THAT BILL IS NOT UP
YET SO IF WE CAN INSURE WERE
SPEAKING ON THE RIGHT BILL
THANK YOU- DR QUIRK THAT GETS
OUT- ON BEHALF MISTER MULLIN
AND OF THE WORLD THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO DO MISTER
CHOOSE BILL. I'M SURE NOT SEEN
MR CHIU THAT WOULD BE FANTASTIC
OKAY NEED TO LOOK AT THE NINE
THANK YOU FOR ALWAYS BEING A
TEAM PLAYER DR QUIRK OUR MOTION
BY MISTER STONE AFFECTED BY
MISS CARILLO. IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED
PROCESS FOR THOSE WHO ARE
UNAWARE OF THE IMMIGRATION
CONSEQUENCES OF THE CONVICTION.
WITH TUITION THE COURT FOR
RESENTENCING OR DISMISSAL.
HOWEVER THIS PROCESS IS ONLY
AVAILABLE WITH THOSE WHO WERE
CONVICTED BY A THREE GARDEN.
THREE BARGAIN IS NOT AVAILABLE
TO THOSE- CONVICTED BY TRIAL.
AB TWELVE FIFTY NINE EXTENDS
THE CURRENT PROCESS TO INCLUDE.
THE INDIVIDUALS COVERED BY JURY
TRIAL- THERE'S AN ESTIMATE IN
THE ANALYSIS. OF THAT ROUGHLY
SEVENTY THOUSAND WOULD BE A
REASONABLE ESTIMATE OF THE VERY
RARE INSTANCES IN WHICH- THIS
WOULD BE APPLICABLE. AND THAT'S
ABOUT ONE TENTH OF 1% OF THE
SEVENTY TWO MILLION THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS ADDING TO THE
BUDGET THIS YEAR. I REQUEST
FULLY ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHU I REQUEST YOU ARRIVE
OUT. THANK YOU. WE WILL GO TO
THE PHONES IF YOU WANT TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB TWELVE FIFTY
NINE I MISTER SHOW. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THE FIRST
ON LINE FORTY TWO. MY NAME IS
CAN STOCKTON PLASTER COUNTY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ONE TWO FIVE
THANK THANK YOUNG. WE HAVE. ONE
SEVENTY FIVE. YES COULD NOT
SERVE HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TERMS OF
CRIMINAL JUSTICE HERE CO
SPONSORED MEASURE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE ELEVEN.
AUTHOR AND WHY DON'T YOU HAVE A
PRIMARY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
THE FOCUSING VERY BALANCED
DISCONNECT THE CALL. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE SIXTY ONE. HEATHER
KELLER SACRAMENTO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ONE TWO FIVE
NINE THANK YOU. LINE. EIGHTY
THIS IS JANET HOW SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE BILL THANK YOU. LINE
SEVENTEEN. THANK YOU CAN ACT ON
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF- AMERICAN
CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION
CALIFORNIA ACTION PROUD CO
SPONSOR IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. YOU HAVE LINE ONE
THIRTY FIVE. YEAH YOUR LINE IS
OPEN OKAY HI I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL WILL FEEL THE L. A.
COUNTY. THERE ARE NO OTHER
LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU WILL BRING THAT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE- AND THAT GETS
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL THANK YOU
DR PERK MR MCCARTY EUROPE. MR
MCCARTY HS AB FOURTEEN NINETY
ONE IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTER STONE A SECOND BY
MISS CARILLO. MR MCCARTY MAY
BEGAN. THANK YOU- MY COLLEAGUE
FRIEND LOS ANGELES IN THE FIFTY
FIRST DISTRICT MISS CARILLO AND
I THINK ARE THE ONLY MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY VIA ADULT
EDUCATION IN THIS- CHAMBER
ITSELF- WE KNOW FIRST HAND THE
ADULT EDUCATION MATTERS FOR
CREDIT RECOVERY FOR PEOPLE
LEARNING- ENGLISH SKILLS AND
FOR JUST THE BASIC ADULT SKILLS
TRAINING AMERICAN OUR STATE
THIS WOULD ENSURE THAT MONIES
ALLOCATED FOR ADULT AD GOES TO
ADULT ADD AND DOES DOES NOT
HAVE AND REASONABLE A HOLDOVER
PROVISION SO THAT PROGRAMS CAN
HARD MONEY. THIS HAS- SUPPORT
FROM OUR ADULT THAT COMMUNITY
AND ASK HERE I DON'T YOU THANK
YOU WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
AS IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO
AB FOURTEEN NINETY ONE. PRESS
ONE ON THEIR- AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE. SIXTY
ONE SIX ONE. HEATHER TAYLOR
FROM SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FOURTEEN
NINETY ONE. WE HAVE LINE ONE
FORTY. HI RES LINE ONE FORTY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE MCCARTY- AND
HIMSELF. THANK YOU ANDREA. WE
HAVE LINE. EIGHTY CHEN AND
HIGHLIGHTS STRONGLY OPPOSED THE
BILL THANK YOU. LINE ONE OH
SEVEN. THANK HERE MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS DON KATHLEEN MCCUE
CAPTAIN IF THIS GETS UP HALF
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
ADULTS EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA
DON'T EDUCATION ADMINISTRATORS
ASSOCIATION A STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NO
FURTHER LINES IN Q. THANK YOU
MR MCCARTY THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL THANK YOU. WILL MOVE
NOW TO MISS CARILLO YOU HAVE AB
FOR FORTY THREE YOU CAN EITHER
PRESENT AT YOUR DESK OR IN THE
BACK IT'S UP TO YOU- IT ENJOYS
EIGHT DO PASS RECOMMENDATION I
HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER STONE A
SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK. THIS
CARILLO. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS SOME PROTESTANT AB
FOUR THIRTY THREE WHICH WOULD
ALLOW INTERNATIONAL MEDICAL
GRADUATES TO PARTICIPATE IN A
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM OFFERED AT A
FEDERAL QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTER
AND RULE OR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND CALIFORNIA THIS
BILL WOULD ALSO EXPAND AN
EXISTING PROGRAM AT THE MEDICAL
BOARD TO ALLOW THE SPECIALTY
FACULTY PERMIT TO BE ISSUED OUT
OF FEDERAL QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTER FOR AN APPLICANT-
FOREIGN POSITION THAT SPEAKS
THE LANGUAGE OF NEED MATCHING
THE PATIENT POPULATION.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE COMMISSION
ABOUT SEVEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS LIVE IN AN AREA
WITH A FOR A SHORTAGE OF
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS THOSE
SHORTAGES ARE CONCENTRATED IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR MANY THE
NEED FOR MULTI LINGUAL
POSITIONS AS A EVEN MORE DIRE
THAN BEFORE- ADDING TO THE
FISCAL ANNOUNCES THE BILL COST
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND. WHICH A
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND OF
THEM. BEING RECOVERED THROUGH
APPLICATION FEES I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AS THE BILL. MOVES
FORWARD AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
WITNESS ON THE PHONE THAT'S BUT
ANYTHING THEM KNOWING IS
CONSTANT VICE PRESIDENT OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS. AND
ENGAGEMENT AND ULTIMATE. DO WE
HAVE THAT ANY FROM THE FOUND.
I'M HERE GOOD MORNING EVERYONE-
MY NAME IS THAT ANYTHING IS
CONTENT ON THE VICE PRESIDENT
OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS INCLUDING
ENGAGEMENT AUGMENT HEALTH
SERVICES WERE A PRODUCT SPONSOR
THAT EIGHTY FOUR FOUR THREE
THIS BILL- REALLY TAKE A STEP
FORWARD TO ADDRESS THE
PHYSICIAN SHORTAGE IN OUR
STATE- BY PROVIDING
INTERNATIONAL MEDICAL GRADUATES
OF THE PATHWAY TO HELP ADDRESS.
THE DIRE PRIMARY CARE GAP THAT
EXISTS FOR CALIFORNIANS
UNDERSERVED AND PRIMARILY UNDER
REPRESENTED MINORITY SO ON
BEHALF OF ULTIMATE HELD
SERVICES SERVING THREE HUNDRED
APPLICATIONS A MONTH AND A
LARGE COUNTY- WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS DOWN. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. DO WE NOW CAN
GO TO THE PHONE LINE TO A UP
FOR. WHO WANTS REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AB FOR
FORD B. THREE. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE HAVE
TWO LINES SPENDING. YEAH A LINE
ONE TWENTY NINE. YEAH I- CUSTOM
INTERNAL HILLS I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE. ONE FORTY
THREE. CAN STOP FROM PLASTER
COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY
FOUR POINT THREE THANK YOU. ONE
EIGHTY. THIS IS SHANNON HOW
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. LINE. ONE FORTY. OPEN THE
BUILDING I'M AGAINST ALL THIS
NONSENSE. OPERATOR CAN YOU
DISCONTENT KNACK THAT LINE
RIGHT SHE CLEARLY CANNOT CALL
THE ROLL MANAGER THANK YOU. ONE
ONE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU DOUG SHIVERS ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA HELP US
ADVOCATES A STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOUNG. NO FOR
THE LINE THANK YOU THANK YOU
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE I SEE NO QUESTIONS
THAT GETS OUT ON IN A ROLL CALL
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO MISTER
CHOW YOU MAY PRESENT FROM YOUR
DESK IF YOU WISH AB SIX NINETY
SEVEN ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A MOTION-
BY MR STONE A SECOND BY MISS
KOREA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS EIGHTY
SIX NINETY SEVEN WOULD CREATE A
PROGRAM FOR THE STATE TO PLAN
MANAGE AND IMPLEMENT FOREST
RESTORATION PROJECTS ON U. S.
FOREST SERVICE LANDS THROUGH AN
EXPANDED AND FORMALIZED GOOD
NEIGHBOR AUTHORITY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU YOU HAVE A WITNESS IS LIZ
FORSBERG. ON THE LINE. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIRPERSON IS
WITH FOR THIRTY MINUTES OF THE
TRACTOR POLICY PROCEDURE
CONSERVANCY WE'RE SPONSORING
EIGHTY SIX NINETY SEVEN.
BALLPARK OF JURISDICTION
BOUNDARIES PROPERTY BUT THE
DOCTOR COOPER ALL IN APPROACH
APPROVED HEALTH THE COVERS ALL
OWNERSHIP YOU CAN HELP. THE
LOCAL STATE PRIVATE BETTER WHEN
IN AB SIX HUNDRED OF THE BY THE
SUPPORT FOR. THE BILL WILL
CLEAR ACCORDING TO THE AND THE
BY GOVERNMENT TO HELP PROTECT
COMMUNITIES AND WE START
TYPICAL ALL CALIFORNIA.
RECOGNIZING THE NEED FOR.
GOVERNMENT AND THE STATE TO
WORK TOGETHER. SO SPORTS HEALTH
CONGRESS INCLUDED THE COULD BE
RESTORED IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN BARBELL. OPPORTUNITY
AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO SIGN
AGREEMENTS THAT ENABLE TO
SHARING A FUN STAFF AND OTHER
RESOURCES ACROSS JURISDICTIONAL
BOUNDARIES. SB SIX TWENTY SEVEN
WHAT EXTEND THE GOOD NEIGHBOR
AUTHORITY IN CALIFORNIA. BUT
WATCHING A FORMAL PROGRAMS THAT
HELP PEOPLE CAPACITY TO STATE
WITH THIS BEFORE PROJECT
PLANNING. APPLICATION UNNATURAL
PORCELAIN. THE PROGRAM IS
FUNDED FROM STATE AND FEDERAL
INVESTMENT THE LAST OF THE
BUDGET CRAZY ACCOUNT REQUIRED
ANY. FOR PROJECT THE RESPECT
TEACHER. COMPANY HAS ALSO THE
BEST INVOLVED REFORM WEEK BE
USED FOR. INCLUDE EVERYTHING
FIVE POINTERS MILLION OR ACTUAL
OFFER. FOR SURE START TO
COMPANIES FORCES CRITICAL TO
REDUCE THE RISK OF WILDFIRES.
WE APPRECIATE SOME OF OUR TOP
LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUE. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ARE THERE IN
OTHER CALL AND SOME- ON. TO AB.
SIX NINETY SEVEN. STATE YOUR
POSITION ON THIS BILL IN A
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NO
LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL BRING
IT BACK I SEE NO QUESTIONS.
FROM THE COMMITTEE THAT GETS
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL WITH-
MISTER ALI AND MISS DAVIES NOT
VOTING. WE WILL. BE WITH I HAD
NO WITH. WELL WE WILL GO TO MY
BILLS WILL MOVE OVER TO EIGHTY
FIVE OH SEX IN THIS GONZALEZ
AND I'M SURE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
FOR PRESENTATION THANK YOU AB
FIVE OR SIX REQUIRES USE WHERE
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO WE HAVE
A SECOND- BY MISTAKE THESE.
THANK YOU- THIS WILL HELP
PREVENT CHILD ABUSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE.
THANK YOU FOR THE BREVITY
THERE- WE HAVE NO WITH MISTER
WITNESSES CAN YOU OPEN THE
PHONES TO THOSE THAT WISH TO
SPEAK EITHER IN FAVOR OR OR
OPPOSITION. YOU TO STATE YOUR
POSITION AB FIVE OR SIX ME
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
AGAIN THAT'S ONE ZERO. FULLER
LINE EIGHTY. BUT LINE REMOVED
ITSELF WHEN ONE FORTY THREE. BY
ONE FORTY THREE ARE YOU THERE.
CAN HE GOT FROM POTTER COUNTY
AND STRONGLY OPPOSED THE CELL.
THANK YOU- NO OTHER LINES IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE MEMBER SEEING
NINE THIS GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. WE HAVE ANOTHER BILL AND
I'M SHARING YOUR BILL FIFTEEN
NINETY THREE. I SEE WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MR LEVINE AND A
SECOND BY MISS CARILLO. THIS
IS- THE ONLY HEARING THIS BILL
GETS BECAUSE IT IS A PRODUCT OF
THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE IT IS A VICTIM
COMPENSATION- CLAIMS BILL THAT
WE HAVE TO CARRY BY LAW. I DO
WANNA EXPRESS IT WILL BE
APPROPRIATE ONE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE GENERAL
FUND SPECIFICALLY FOR TWO
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE WRONGLY
IMPRISONED DEREK HARRIS WHO
SPENT SEVEN YEARS IN JAIL. FOR
ROBBERY HE DID NOT COMMIT AND-
NINE HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY
DOLLARS FOR JEREMY POCKET FOR
HIS WRONGFUL. CONVICTION AND
IMPRISONMENT FOR NINETEEN YEARS
FOR A ROBBERY AND MURDER HE DID
NOT COMMIT. LET'S PLEASE GET
THIS OUT QUICKLY TO TRY TO
PROVIDE SOME RELIEF FOR THOSE
WHO ARE WRONGLY IMPRISONED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE HAVE
NO- WITNESSES WILL OPEN THE
PHONE LINES FOR SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION. STRAWBERRY- ONE
THANK YOU YOU MAY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE EIGHTY EIGHT ZERO.
HI THIS IS SHANNON HEIL IMPACT
NOT COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THE BILL. WE HAVE
LINE SIXTY ONE. HEATHER KELLER
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL. LINE.
ONE FORTY THREE. WHAT'S YOUR
COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB.
ONE FIVE NINE THREE. SPYING ONE
FORTY ONE. ANTHONY RANGEL FROM
PIZZAGATE HEALING ALLIANCE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
NINE ONE FIFTY. IN FIVE LETTER
ON YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES. SO
IT'S FOR THE WATER RIGHT TO
OPPOSE IT. AB. FIFTEEN NINETY
THREE. SB FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR
I BELIEVE THE OTHER ON THE BILL.
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO FOR
THE LINES IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BRING IT BACK TO THE FLOOR
ARE THERE ANY CONCERNS OR
QUESTIONS BY MEMBERS SEEING NON
THAT BILL GETS OUT ON AN EIGHTY.
ROLL CALL. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU- I DO WANT TO
GO BACK TO EIGHTY SIX NINETY
SEVEN MISTER CHAO'S BILL EIGHT
WE- READ OUT THE VOTE A LITTLE.
WRONG LET ME TRY THIS AGAIN
WHERE IT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING EXCEPT MR BIGELOW IS THE
NO. CORRECT. REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. MISTER BIGELOW IS THE
NOW. GAYVN MYSTERIOUS IS A NINE
OKAY OKAY. PICKED UP A VOTE
THERE MR CHA. ALL RIGHT- AT
THIS POINT WE WILL- TAKE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW A
SECOND BY MIST- CREO CAN YOU
PLEASE READ- THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MR SECRETARY. AB ZERO
THREE BOERNER HORVATH AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO CHAO AB TEN
OH TWO CHOI AB NINE INTO COOLEY
AB TEN NINETY FIVE COOLEY AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE COOPER AB
TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN CUNNINGHAM.
AB ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR FLOOR AB
THREE OH NINE GABRIEL EIGHTY
FOUR NINETY ONE LORENA GONZALEZ
AB EIGHT EIGHT ONE LEARNING AND
SALAS AB ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR
GRAYSON A. B. NINE SIX TWO
KAMLAGER. AB THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE MATHIS AB THREE TWENTY
MEDINA AB THREE THREE FORMALIN
AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY FOUR MULLIN
AB EIGHT SEVEN THREE RAMOS AB
TWELVE TWENTY THREE OF US A
BEFORE ELEVEN FORTY FOUR ROBERT
RIVAS. AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
RODRIGUEZ AB. THREE TWO TWO
SALAS AB TWELVE SAY ARTO AB
NINE ONE THREE SMITH AB THIRTY
THREE TANG AB. FOURTEEN FIFTY
TO TEN EIGHTY ELEVEN FORTY NINE
VIA- AB FIFTEEN ELEVEN
COMMITTEE ON INSURANCE AB
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR COMMITTEE
ON HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. THANK YOU THAT
GETS OUT THE CONSENT CALENDAR
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL AT THIS
TIME WE WILL READ ALL OF THE
BILLS THAT ARE BEING MOVED TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE IT IS A LOT
OF THEM SO I APPRECIATE THIS IN
ADVANCE MR SECRETARY. AB
FOURTEEN AGUIAR-CURRY EIGHTY
FIVE THIRTY TO AT YOUR CARRY
EIGHTY FORTY FIVE AYE YOU'RE
CARRY A LOT OF HUNDRED
AGUIAR-CURRY. EIGHTY FOR AMBLE
AB SIX THIRTY ARRIVAL AB SIX
NINE FIVE ARAMBULA AB TEN
NINETY FOUR AVALON. AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY SIX ARAMBULA AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY ARRIVAL AB FOUR TO SEVEN
POWER QUE HAN. AB SIXTY FOUR OF
OUR QUE HAN EIGHTY TEN. TEN
THIRTY THREE OF OUR QUE HAN AB
TWELVE FORTY TWO HOUR CAN. AB
FIFTEEN TWELVE HOUR KAY HONEY
BEEF EIGHT TWO SIX BENNETT A.
B. TEN FIFTY ONE BENNETT AB
NINE TWO EIGHT. BERMAN AB
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX BERMAN AB
TEN SIXTY SIX BLOOM. AB TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO BELOW MAYBE FOURTEEN
FIFTY FOUR BALLOON MAYBE
FOURTEEN NINETY TO BLOOM. A. B.
SIX EIGHTY BURKE AB NINE SIX
SIX BURKE AB TWELVE SIX ONE
BURKE. SB SIX ONE NINE CALDERON
AB SIX SEVENTY CALDERON AB FOR
EIGHTY CARILLO AB SEVEN NINE
FOUR CARILLO. AB EIGHT NINETY
SEVEN DAYS AB ELEVEN OH SIX OR
FIVE DAYS AB FOURTEEN SIX SEVEN
CERVANTES. AB TWO EIGHT CHAO AB
THREE FIVE CHAO AB THREE FIVE
SIX CHEN. AB TWO ONE FIVE CHIU
AB FOUR EIGHT ONE CHIU AB SIX
TO NINE CHIU AB EIGHT ONE SIX
CHIU AB EIGHT EIGHT SIX TWO. AB
TEN EIGHTY SEVEN SHOULD AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY THREE CHU. AB
SIX ONE NINE CHOI EIGHTY SIX
FORTY COOLEY AB TWELVE FIFTY
FOUR COOLEY AT FOURTEEN FORTY
SEVEN COOLEY. AB THREE FIVE
FOUR COOPER EIGHTY SIX FIVE
SEVEN COOPER. AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT CUNNINGHAM AB EIGHT SIX
SIX MILLION DOLLARS EIGHTY NINE
EIGHT ZERO MEGAN DOLLY. AB
SEVENTY ONE DALY AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY THREE DALY AB FIFTEEN
SIXTY DALY. AB SEVEN NINE TWO
FOUR AB NINETY FRAZIER. SB SIX
FOUR TWO FRIEDMAN AB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ONE FRIEDMAN. AB SIXTY
ONE GABRIEL AB FIVE EIGHT SEVEN
GABRIEL AB SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN
GABRIEL AB AB NINETY NINE
GABRIEL AB THIRTEEN BEFORE
GABRIEL. AB ONE CRISTINA GARCIA
AB THREE SIX SEVEN CRISTINA
GARCIA. AB SEVEN ONE THREE
CRISTINA GARCIA AB THIRTEEN
FORTY ONE CRISTINA GARCIA. SB
SIX TO EIGHT EDUARDO GARCIA AB
EIGHT SIX EIGHT AND WATER. CA
AB TEN THIRTY SIX EDUARDO
GARCIA AB ELEVEN SIX NINE AND
WATER SO. AT ELEVEN. SEVENTY
SIX EDUARDO GARCIA. SB SEVEN
FOUR FIVE GIPSON EIGHTY NINE
FIVE EIGHT GIPSON AB ELEVEN
SIXTY FIVE GIPSON AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY FIVE GIPSON. AB NINE
NINE FIVE LEARNING GONZALEZ AB
TEN OH THREE LEARNING AND SALAS
AB TWO TO FIVE GRAVY NINE SEVEN
ONE GRAVY TEN FIFTY GRAY. SB
SIX OH TWO GRAYSON AB EIGHT OR
SEVEN GRAYSON AB TEN EIGHTY
NINE GRAYSON. AB ONE OH FIVE
HOLDEN AB THREE FOUR NINE
HOLDEN AB NINE FOUR EIGHT
HOLDEN. AB NINE NINE IRWIN
EIGHTY THREE TO FIVE OR ONE
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY ONE IRWIN AB
EIGHT OR NINE IRWIN AB TEN
SEVENTY IRWIN. AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT IRWIN AB NINETY
FOUR JONES SAWYER AB EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT JONES SAWYER AB THIRTY
KALRA. AB ELEVEN NINETY TWO
KALRA AB THREE STE NINE SIX
THREE COME LATER. AB TEN
SEVENTY SIX KILEY AB SEVEN
SIXTY LACKEY EIGHTY SEVEN SIX
TWO LEE. AB FIFTEEN OH NINE LEE
AB NINE SIX FIVE LEVINE AB
TWELVE TWENTY THREE LEVINE
ADDED AB SIXTY FIVE LOW. AB
FIVE SIX TWO LOW AB TEN EIGHTY
FOUR LOW AB ELEVEN EIGHTEEN
LOW. AB THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
LOW AB THREE OH FIVE
MAIENSCHEIN. AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY MATHIS AB TEN FOURTEEN
MCCARTY. AB THIRTEEN FORTY
EIGHT MCCARTY AB A FOURTEEN
FORTY THREE MCCARTY AB FIFTEEN
FORTY TWO MCCARTY AB THREE SIX
THREE MEDINA. AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SIX MEDINA AB EIGHT ONE THREE
MULLIN AB EIGHT NINE SEVEN
MULLIN A BEFORE SEVEN FIVE
WORDS TO CHEAT. AB FIVE ELEVEN
MURATSUCHI AB FIVE THREE EIGHT
MURATSUCHI. SB SIX FIFTY
MURATSUCHI AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
THREE MURATSUCHI. AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY NINE IS AREA AB THIRTEEN
THIRTY SIX TO WIN. AB FIVE
EIGHT SIX OR DONALD AB FIFTEEN
TWEEN TWENTY FOUR O'DONNELL AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY ONE O'DONNELL.
AB SIX SEVEN PETRIE-NORRIS AB
ONE TEN PETRIE-NORRIS AB FOUR
HUNDRED PETRIE-NORRIS AB ELEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT PETRIE-NORRIS A. B.
SEVEN OH SEVEN QUIRK EIGHTY
NINE FIVE FIVE COURT. AB TWELVE
NINETY FOUR QUIRKY AB EIGHT
SEVEN FOR QUICK SILVA. AB TEN
SEVENTEEN CORK SILVA AB. TEN
NINETY CORD BLOOD. AB TWO TO
SAY RAMOS A. B. TEN FIFTY FIVE
RAMOS A BEEF SO REYES. AB
NINETY TWO A. AS AB TEN SEVENTY
TWO REYES AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
FIVE REYES. AB SEVENTY ONE
THREE OF US AB SEVEN RODRIGUEZ
AB FIFTY FIVE FOUR FIVE FOUR
RODRIGUEZ SB SIX SIX TWO
RODRIGUEZ AB TEN SIXTY
RODRIGUEZ. A. B. ELEVEN OH FIVE
RODRIGUEZ AB TWELVE SEVENTEEN
RODRIGUEZ. AB TWELVE TWENTY
NINE RODRIGUEZ AB FIFTY SIX ALL
S. A. B. TEN ONE OH SIX SOLACE.
AB ONE OF SEVEN SALAS EIGHTY
FOUR OH FOUR SALAS AB TWELVE
SIXTEEN SALAS AB FOUR FIVE
SEVEN SANTIAGO. AB FIVE SEVEN
ZERO SAN DIEGO EIGHTY NINE OH
SEVEN SANTIAGO EIGHTY NINE
NINETY SANTIAGO AB ELEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN SANTIAGO. AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN SANTIAGO
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY SAN DIAGO AB
EIGHT OH EIGHT STONE AB FIVE
SIX WANTING. AB NINE SIXTY TANG
AB TWELVE THIRTY SIXTEEN AB
TWELVE THIRTY SEVENTEEN AB
THIRTEEN AWAITING. AB FIFTEEN
FORTY TANG AB TWO FIFTY EIGHT
V. APPROVED WHAT EIGHTY THREE
FIFTY BE APPROVED RIGHT. AB
TWELVE FOURTEEN WALDRON EIGHTY
FIVE HUNDRED WARD AB NINE FIFTY
WARD EIGHTY FOUR OH TWO WICKS
AB FIVE TO EIGHT WEEKS. A. B.
TEN FORTY ONE WAX. AB ELEVEN
NINETEEN WICKS AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT WICKS AB THIRTEEN FORTY
FIVE WICKS A. B. FOURTEEN OH
FIVE WEEKS. AB NINE WOULD AB
FORTY ONE WOULD EIGHTY SIX
SEVEN ONE WOULD EIGHT AB EIGHT
ONE SEVEN WOOD. AB EIGHT SEVEN
TWO WOULD A. B. FOUR EIGHT SIX
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION. AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE COMMITTEE
ON BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS AB
FIFTEEN SIXTY SEVEN COMMITTEE
ON EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AB
FIFTEEN SIXTY NINE COMMITTEE ON
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT. AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY ONE COMMITTEE
ON JOBS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ECONOMY AND FIFTEEN SEVENTY
THREE COMMITTEE ON JOBS.
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND THE
ECONOMY. WOW ALL RIGHT ALL OF
THOSE BILLS- THANK GOD- THE
AUTHORS HAVE WAIVED
PRESENTATION AND THOSE ARE
MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE IF
YOU ARE. LOOKING TO COMMENT
YOUR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO
ANY OF THOSE BILLS THAT WERE
JUST MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE. WE WILL OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES FOR YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF YOU HAVE ONE IN
THE BILL THAT YOU ARE
SUPPORTING OR OPPOSING THAT IS
ALL YOU SHOULD STATE NOT THE
REASON WHY AT THIS POINT.
DISTRIBUTOR THANK YOU YOU MAY
PRESS ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN THEY'LL TO SHARE THAT
INFORMATION. GO FIRST TO LINE
FORTY SIX. BURKE WHITE HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS I HAVE A LITTLE
LADY WITH SO- PLEASE BEAR WITH
ME AS I GO IT I AB TWO
FIFTEENTHS OF I HAVE CALIFORNIA
YOU CANDY PART. HAVEN'T HAPPENS
MANY. THE COMPUTER CO CAN'T
PROPERTY- FOR THE SECOND
PLANNING AND URBAN THAT PATIENT
CALCULUS AND BUILD BILL PENDING
HOW. AND ASK CBI. AB FIVE EIGHT
SUPPORT YEAH HAVE TECHNICIAN
CAL. AB FIVE ONE OF CALIFORNIA
BE TMG PART CONSIDER COALITION
DEAL THAN COMPANY EBITA FOR AB
THIRTY ONE FOR THE CALL HAVE
FOR HUMANITY TO HELP AND HELP
GIVE THE FRONT. FEELS BETTER
COMPANY. IN SUPPORT HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA AB TWELVE
TWENTY IN SUPPORT CALIFORNIA
YIMBY- AB ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR
IN SUPPORT CALIFORNIA FANTAIL
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY TMG
PARTNERS BECAUSE HE TO
COALITION COUNCIL AND THE
BUILDER FOR GIFTED AND COMPANY
CPA. AB ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT AT
THE PORT. CALIFORNIA YOU'D BE.
AB THIRTY I HAVE NAMED ROBERT
CAL IN SUPPORT. AB. THREE SIX
SEVEN FIVE ZERO AND IN A
MAINTENANCE SUPPORT. AB. COOPER
EIGHTY AT TEN FORTY ONE NERO
AND SEE AN AMAZING. AND. EIGHTY
ELEVEN NINETEEN I NAY RAPID
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE WANTS
REGISTER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
YEP LINE. SEVENTY NINE. HI GOOD
MORNING CHARACTER LAWS ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT OF
AB FOURTEEN AGUIAR-CURRY AB
NINETY NINE IRWIN AND. EIGHTEEN
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX MEDINA THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NINE ONE FIFTY
SIX. GOOD MORNING THIS SPEND
OUR SHOW THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OPPOSITION HI WE ARE SUPPORTER
AB SEVENTY TWO TO RAINY AND
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY SIX
O'DONNELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
BYE IN. ONE FIFTY FIVE. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS ON THE TROUBLES
ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC ADVOCATES
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO HELLO- WE
ARE CO SPONSORS THANK YOU.
THANK YOUNG. ONE FIFTY EIGHT.
HI MY NAME IS CHETNA SCOTTY AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. LINE TWENTY SEVEN.
EILEEN BROKEN COALITION FOR SAN
FRANCISCO NEIGHBORHOODS
SPEAKING ON MY OWN BEHALF AB
FOURTEEN R. WE ARE CURRENTLY
SUPPORT AB FORTY ONE WOULD
SUPPORT AB TWO ONE FIVE TO
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FOUR NINETY
ONE GONZALEZ SUPPORT AB FIVE
SIXTY ONE PAYING SUPPORT EIGHTY
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN GABRIEL
SUPPORT AB EIGHT OH THREE
BOERNER HORVATH SUPPORT EIGHTY
NINE EIGHTY NINE GABRIEL OPPOSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU
EIGHTY WE HAVE NO OPERATOR
WHAT- WE CAN DO IS IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO ONE OF THE BILLS
HAD BEEN MOVED TO SUSPENSE AND
YOU GOT DISCONNECTED YOU CAN-
EMAIL OUR OFFICES OR SEND IN ON
YOUR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION-
THAT CALENDAR WILL BE DISPENSED
OF. NEXT THURSDAY MAY THE
TWENTIETH SO PLEASE GET YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AND
BEFORE THAT DATE WITH THAT I'M
SORRY THAT THE OPERATOR GOT
DISCONNECTED THERE'S NOT MUCH
WE CAN DO WITH THAT THAT
CONCLUDES THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.